CMT has been very kind to us and we're
it's a network that we fit into very
very good so all the people there are
very encouraging and for people who
watched you all those years on A&E and
wondered what resulted in the end of the
relationship what would you say to that
well Annie was a you know gave us Nancy
Dubuque I'm talking about gave us our
first boost in life so we owe her from
the beginning to the end we had you know
nine years was a very good run we did I
think 200 or almost 300 shows there so
we did very very good we had no regrets
at all from Annie they paid us every
time we did she know they they were good
about you know paying us and they they
were very very good and I learned a lot
most Americans got to know you before
they were even using Facebook now social
media is a part of everyday life how
does that affect how you do a television
show when you know that people are going
to be reacting on Facebook reacting on
Twitter well I think and I think it's a
fantastic thing in a lot of rural
communities in America which we've been
working this season there is no
telephone service there's no cell
service anywhere so Facebook is the art
of communications all over the country
we use it in now in our you know in our
job to hunt also because you'd be
surprised this season you'll see a lot
of people bragging the dog is looking
for me ha ha ha you know and we track
them through Facebook and through
Twitter and and through Instagram I mean
it's it's incredible so we can use all
those things to our advantage more than
our disadvantage so having a smartphone
in your pocket can make it easier to
track down criminals having any kind of
telephone in your pocket as long as it's
the batteries on can make it difficult
to hide you know there were some rumors
a while back that you wanted to go after
the NSA leaker Edward Snowden can you
just set the record straight on that you
know I think Edwards
Snowden he'd landed in Hawaii he's from
Hawaii so I had a couple tips from an
ex-girlfriend where he was going but you
can't just butt into things where you
don't belong so we haven't been asked to
do anything about him at all no now
we've been watching your adventures on
television for more than a decade now
how long do you do you want to keep
doing TV well I just told Beth the other
day that I was going to take this 15
minutes to my grave
so I huh we try to retire you know after
ane and and I just can't fish that many
hours in a day